it's it's hard to navigate that space
but don't take it from luke
take it from joe biden oh who said
there's no federal solution to the covet
19 pandemic that means every bit of
guidance you you really got to
understand what joe biden said when he
made this statement there's no federal
solution to coven that means everything
fauci said
has been what
a lie a waste of our time yeah what do
you mean there's no federal solution joe
no no no no hold on people need to
understand a lot of people are like joe
biden's giving up a lot of people are
saying he's coming to to realize
whatever it is
that statement is joe biden undermining
the entire federal response
if there's no solution at the federal
level what have we been doing the states
have been taking guidance from you from
fauci you take a look at what andrew
cuomo said when he killed all those
people in the nursing home he said we
were getting federal guidance our is joe
biden now coming out and saying
everything they did was not in the
effort to produce a solution to this
then what are they doing and why is
fauci still talking fire the guy joe
biden if there's no federal solution
then what is fauci doing the airlines
okay no more restrictions on airlines
you can have your new year's parties
because we can't do any of it it's got
to be the states
this is this is this is much bigger than
i think people realize what joe biden
said this is enormous i actually learned
about this today i'm like whoa because
you know we're just we're in the green
room doing our thing hanging out and i'm
like
this is huge yeah like this is literally
10th amendment stuff man like since when
did democrats care about the 10th
amendment let me let me let me read some
of this okay so i was in office they did
biden held the phone conference the
nation's governors monday as coveted
cases began to rise when speaking to
arkansas governor aza hutchinson biden
said there's no federal solution quote
one word of cons uh one word of concern
or encouragement for your team is that
as you look towards federal solutions
that will help alleviate the challenge
make sure that we do not let federal
solutions stand in the way of state
solutions the production of 500 million
rapid tests that will be distributed by
the federal government is great but
obviously that drives up the supply
chain for the solutions that we might
offer as governor there is no federal
solution this gets solved at the state
level biden responded so that was asa
biden responded there is no federal
solution okay the president the united
states has said
everything that they've done
was not
heading in the direction of a solution
it was not solution oriented then why
are we doing it
this is this literally ran on the
platform of ending coven
that was literally his thing i will end
covid and instead we get more coven we
get more people who've had the procedure
getting coven it didn't stop the
transmission i think we have record case
new york city accounts didn't new york
city i think i read this 25 of the
positive covet cases in new york city
one of the most vaccinated places in the
country i believe that's 25 let's look
it up i think it's 25.
if i'm mistaken then i'm gonna blame it
on someone else okay well new york is
breaking records
they're seeing uh nearly uh i don't know
about that that 25 statistic but new
york city is breaking records with
massive amounts of cases so i'll put it
this way i want i want to make sure i
can say something
thank you joe biden
you are correct yeah the solution here
has always been state level the federal
guidance is proving to be inadequate and
joe biden has correctly pointed it out
and it was the right thing to do and i'm
glad he did because now we can take a
look at florida all right florida's
doing fantastic at the state level they
have rejected
early this year i pointed out that joe
biden came out and said we may need more
lockdowns x y and z and all the things
you want to do and i was like he's not
talking to red states he's talking to
blue states because the red states are
not listening to him and you know what
florida has been way better off for it
you look at the gulf states and for some
reason they have these areas that are
doing really really well i wonder why
that is well so long as they are able as
states to handle their own issues it
seems to be working out and the big blue
states that are just following federal
guidelines
executed a bunch of old people in
nursing homes because they were like
we're following federal guidelines well
that was under trump sure
but it was the governors who did it if
joe biden is going to come out right now
and say the f there's no federal
solution
okay then fauci can say whatever he
wants but it seems to be meaningless
it's going to have to be state level
it's going to be localized it took him
long enough and he saw did a lot of
damage and and it seems like almost
every action he committed he made the
situation that much worse i just posted
a meme of of the simpsons and it's the
classroom where it's where it's the all
the students looking back at this one
one kid and says say the line and then
biden is in the middle and he's like
covet is a state issue and everyone's
celebrating and cheering and then this
is this is the moment that we reached
that we finally have this crescendo of
the state realizing its ineptness it's
its inability to to take care of the
situation and at least it has
the the ability to see that it took a
very long time there was a lot of damage
done to the average american but it
should have always been a state issue
because states based on their
populations based on their circumstances
know what's right for their constituents
a lot more than a centralized top-down
federal force that again
boggled this response from the very
beginning and it can't even get testing
right botched yes
let's some states just really like being
told what to do let's new york loves
that stuff let's pull up politifact
this is the joe biden promise fact
checker
and one of his first promises get covet
19 under control
according to politifact the biden
promise tracker says this one is in the
works
joe biden quote i'm never going to raise
the white flag and surrender we're going
to beat this virus we're going to get it
under control i promise you
okay politifact you need to go into your
biden promise tracker and where it says
in the works put surrendered
or failed whatever
if joe biden's promise was to get
covered under control but his response
now to governor says hey don't look at
us you guys got to solve this problem
you can call it a white flag i think
it's a fair point joe biden said he
wouldn't raise it but he's certainly
raising it right now you're absolutely
correct i mean look you you can't go and
say that we need to do things federally
we need to get everybody to do this that
in the third and then all of a sudden be
like ah nah nah this has always been a
state's issue
all we've heard is like he federal
mandates he's got the data and he goes
oh we screwed up really no no he didn't
say that he's sitting in his room and
he's like listen
we're working hard on this one at the
federal level to get things done uh mr
biden president here's your updated
numbers and and we're going to fight
hard to
it's a states issue um
after reviewing the data uh i've always
said it was a states issue look man
if he's now admitting the right thing
i'm glad he's doing it but it is this is
indicative of a bigger problem here in
this country that people voted for a
corporeal form that's what the atlantic
said they didn't vote for a man who was
going to lead they voted for a man who
was not trump that's it they put him and
put him in his little wheelchair put the
blanket oh i gotta i gotta bring it up i
gotta say it joe biden said let's go
brandon joe biden himself
he said let's go brennan
he is so out of it he has no idea what's
going on that people are literally
chanting let's go let's go brandon they
say let's go biden let's go brandon
let's go brandon and joe biden doesn't
know
that's how clueless he is how do you not
know i literally have a christmas
ornament that says let's go brandon
amazing it's pretty cool my neighbor
gave it to me
look
joe biden is so out of it and not paying
attention
he did not know that at stadiums across
the country people were chanting let's
go brandon that there's merchandise
you'd think someone would have briefed
him on this like hey you need to know
this is instead he gets a phone call and
the guy's like merry christmas and let's
go brandon he goes yeah i agree let's go
brandon it's like wow maybe he did no
but he forgot like the guy is like 800
years old the emperor has no clothes
he's got dementia he's got alzheimer's
you've got every disease you could get
above 80. like first of all why do we
have someone that damn old in office
second of all like he's not aging well
like look man i'm not a trump guy i'm
not again like you i like him for some
reason i voted for trump but like trump
is a really really
vibrant and healthy 70 plus year old
right
i don't the dude got younger since he's
been in office he's been losing weight
he looks great biden is like weekend at
bernie's like he's the walking dead well
i'll
i'll put it this way yes
trump during his presidency
he was an overweight man
he was not he was not a bastion of
health he
he he loved mcdonald's but wasn't he he
was on a bunch of medications he's an
older guy too
but his mind was at least still trump
joe biden is the true nana shaba de
pressure president
we don't know what that was or why or
batacaf care
i'm sorry
one thing that really gets made
everything biden does
is that he may as well just be saying
those words over and over again
how can we trust him when he comes out
and says it's not a federal issue what
if he meant something else in fact i'll
give you a really good example it was at
i think a u.n meeting he kept referring
to syria as libya
now how do we know that honestly we
don't journalists just told us he met
syria here's the problem
joe biden's speaking to a bunch of
nations about conflict in middle east
let's say he genuinely meant to talk
about the conflict in syria
what if there's someone who's there who
doesn't speak english and hears joe
biden talk and the translator says joe
biden wants military action in libya
they're going to go okay
how are they supposed to know that joe
biden made a mistake and was talking
about something else is there translator
going to come well he said libya but he
meant syria they're gonna be like he
said libya what are you talking about
joe biden using the wrong name of a
country could you imagine they're like
we need to get a military strike today
on where libya okay and they fire
missiles and then he goes like oh i'm in
syria worse still what if joe biden did
not mean syria what if he actually meant
libya because his brain is trapped in
2010 because he's old and demented and
so he's standing at the ui and other
problems in libya man yeah there were
problems in libya with gaddafi and maybe
joe biden can't remember what's going on
and so he's actually thinking about a
problem that's not currently happening i
mean libya's got its problems the fact
is
i don't even know that joe biden meant
to say the word federal and if these
things keep happening how can we trust a
word out of his damn mouth he could come
out and be like we gotta uh we gotta
cure we gotta fight uh kovid and he
actually meant to say fight four coven
he's actually on the side of the virus i
have no idea what the government has
been doing there's an argument to make
there and when he would have bombed
libya the media would have been like joe
biden and slavery in africa bravely
committing an act against the slave
trade that was created there with the
vacuum of power that was created by our
first bombs now we've got more bombs
there you know it would've been funny if
when joe biden was giving this speech
and they the media translates for him
and they're like he meant to say syria
okay sure maybe he did
but if he accidentally says libya and
that results in an accidental airstrike
on um
he accidentally says libya and it
results in an accidental airstrike on
libya then the media is going to be like
this is a good thing
it doesn't matter whether it was the
right country or not they're going to be
like joe biden made it very fierce they
would they would they would find a way
to argue that joe biden was doing this
on purpose he wasn't in fact a demented
and firing missile the wrong country
they would say something like joe biden
had been secretly planning for months
now a strike on militia forces in libya
and the slave trade so here's a question
real quick so trump's out of office
obviously the media hated trump why is
the media still so
protective of president biden stribalism
okay pure tribalism i i think people
need to understand that there's there is
an element of propaganda to it there's
some viral article going around about
some leftist youtuber actually being
like funded by british intelligence or
something yeah sure these are these
things exist of course they do there's
information warfare but for the most
part take a look at uh uh you know brian
stelter on cnn count how many times he
criticizes rachel maddow for being wrong
i can't he blocked me oh yeah it's a
shame i i made fun of his weight
oh well he's really fat look he is but
uh i i i like to keep it to the keep to
the ideas right yeah and if his idea of
a good show is to be like fox news is
bad but literally never complain oh i
should say figuratively never complain
about msnbc or rachel maddow then he's
not a real journalist he's just this is
this is look we can come on this show
over and over again and be like here are
the things we don't like about trump
hear the things we like about trump also
joe biden's crazy and they act like
that's a hyper-partisan show that's like
grifting or whatever and i'm like dude
brian selter cnn msnbc they literally
lie to your faces we aren't fox news
we're not we're not we're not repeating
hannity's lines here we we have we have
arguments about this stuff
but i don't think they can handle those
kinds of these kinds of conversations it
has to be it has to be completely tribal
cnn
built up an anti-trump audience
if they come out now it's called
audience capture and they say
actually trump did well in these areas
their audience would revolt if they come
out now and criticize rachel maddow
their audience would revolt so they
don't do it that's it that's the demise
of their network so
you know
it's too bad it's too bad i mean that
sarcastically it's too bad but it you
know i i wish we had better media i
think these developments prove my
earlier hypotheses that the president is
a puppet that there's multinational
corporations and powerful people behind
him especially at the helms of power
that truly do pull the strings that do
set the policies and i think they're
using his presidency as a lame duck
presidency in order to jam through some
of the most unpopular craziest insane
policies that violate people's human
rights that destroy their ability to
have any financial mobility they're
using him as this kind of trojan horse
this docile
old sleeping man and they're ramming
through some of the top-notch globalist
insanity that that no one would ever
want but but to me he's the perfect
cover and an excuse to do that and i
think
because again he's clearly not there who
else is there i believe the special
interest those special interests i think
are there no matter who is president and
i think that a lot of them do call the
shots with a lot of the unpopular
policies that are passed they're going
to update this politifact fact checker
on like biden's promise tracker and
they're gonna say promise accomplished
like he meant he wa he got covered under
control and that's why he's saying
there's no federal solution because he's
already got under control and now he's
just talking about other stuff is
unrelated to getting under control
because you know he's done well this is
going to be interesting because i think
in a few weeks he's going to be claiming
that he's the victor he took down covid
because a lot of people now when they're
getting this new omnicron uh variant a
lot of people are building up immunity a
lot of people are getting this sickness
so there is a possibility here according
to some medical professionals that this
could be the end of covet with how
virulent this virus is and how less
lethal it is compared to other variants
and for a lot of people this is the best
case scenario because this signals the
end of all of this i have to disagree
with you man i had a runny nose once
that thing annoyed me yo have you ever
seen this video where they simulate a
runny nose with like uv ink or whatever
and so they have a party everyone plays
games and they have a very light runny
nose and it's ink and then at the end of
the of like the party they put a black
light on this they show this is crazy i
can't remember where i saw this many of
you probably seen the video it's like
you see him wipe his nose with a kleenex
and they show the black light you can
see the the ink coming out and then
at the end of the day you can see the
whole room is just covered in the ink
because people would be touching
everything it's really crazy man look i
got no problem saying if you're sick
don't come to my parties look man i'm
sorry you can't calm but don't get
people sick don't do that stuff when
you're sick stay home like yeah my
daughter had a wrestling meet she had a
a little like stuffy nose i'm like
you're gonna be like grappling with
people yeah don't take the day off take
the day off go watch some netflix yeah
just chill i mean that's the problem i
mean when we were sick as a kid we
stayed home from school
we stayed home that's the answer thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you